in news ish today we are talking about
super fast jets ariane is moving forward
with a 12 passenger business plane that
flies from London to New York in four
and a half hours according to The Wall
Street Journal the plane is set to cost
120 million dollars go four thousand
seven hundred fifty knots at up to 1.5
times the speed of sound
David you found this story this is your
dream you talk about a 1% problem this
is 1/100 of 1% one hundred and twenty
million dollars so you can shave two and
a half hours off of your translate
flight I was gonna say so you're not
really saving a lot of time for what I'm
guessing is a lot of expense right that
goes more just you know it goes Mach 1.5
one and a half times the speed well
here's what I'm here's what struck me is
that the the Concorde was already there
and it worked for the rich it turns out
that the economics are such that a plane
built for the super-rich is totally
feasible whereas the conquered couldn't
actually work anymore by the way this
will be a new way of compensating your
CEO forget forget that the Gulfstream
you know he's gonna need a supersonic no
boards are kind of saying the timing
works out for that there's a certain
convenience in being able to sleep
overnight on a transatlantic flight
right so do I now get up at two o'clock
in the morning to get it confuses me I
don't know but I think it may be a
status thing I'm not sure you think he
said love to fly one of those things all
right there weren't you I mean it'll be
fun the London bureau is calling David
it cuts the Charter one of those